EU Health ministers will be looking at
two draft regulations concerning medical
devices and invitro medical
devices the revision of the EU laws on
this matter would ensure the highest
level of protection for European
patients consumers and healthc Care
Professionals it would also guarantee
that safe effective and Innovative
medical devices can be placed on the
market and made available to users in a
timely manner ministers are expected to
adopt conclusions on
vaccinations member states will be
invited to continue improving their
National vaccination programs and raise
public Awareness on the the council will
also adopt conclusions on patient safety
and quality of care that is to improve
the prevention and control of Health
Care Associated infections and
antimicrobial resistance medical
Innovation is also on the agenda
conclusions will be adopted to speed up
the approval of new medicines and to
make them more more affordable to
patients on other matters member states
will be asked by Luxembourg that
excluding people from giving blood
should be linked to highrisk behavior
and not to sexual
orientation Spain is expected to call
member states to sign the convention
against trafficking of human
organs and finally the commission will
update the Council on the Ebola
situation